Middle chapters usually take beloved characters
to some pretty dark places.
We know "Across the Spider-Verse" is the second
part of a trilogy, so does Miles Morales end
up at a low point in this part of his multiversal
journey?
Warning: Spoilers for "Across the Spider-Verse"
ahead!
The first half of "Across the Spider-Verse"
follows Miles and Gwen Stacy on parallel journeys.
Both struggle to balance crime-fighting with
their day-to-day lives and wind up feeling
alone as a result.
After Miles gets pulled into Gwen’s new
gig as a dimension-hopping timeline protector,
however, things pick up speed.
They meet Miguel O'Hara, also known as Spider-Man
2099, and his "Spider-Society."
Their mission is to protect "canon events"
in the Spider-Verse: things like the death
of an uncle, or of a particular police captain.
Miles wants no part of Miguel’s tyrannical
plan, so he runs.
But as he does, he learns that his role in
this web is much larger than just being one
more friendly neighborhood Spider-Man.
"Stop what you're doing and stop Spider-Man!"
"You?
You?
Me?
You?"
"Miles!'
Miguel reveals that Miles is "the original
anomaly" that first threw the Spider-Verse
into disarray.
Because the spider that gave Miles his powers
was from Earth 42 rather than his own dimension,
the cosmic spider balance was thrown off.
Ostensibly, that event sparked all the multiversal
chaos that we’ve seen in the films thus far.
That’s why The Spot is such a perfect villain
for the film.
Not only does he possess transdimensional
powers, but he’s also the scientist who
brought over the spider that later bit Miles.
The idea that his Spider-Man transformation
caused more harm than good rattles Miles,
but he refuses to give up on himself.
Anomaly or not, Miles insists that Miguel’s
way of thinking is flawed.
He disagrees with the idea that certain people
have to die for the universe to be in balance.
Miguel insists that messing with the canon
only brings destruction, even going so far
as to say that Miles is the reason his universe’s
Peter Parker died.
It’s also implied, and then confirmed later
in the film, that Earth 42 must have suffered
after losing its intended Spider-Man.
Enraged by Miles’ disobedience, Miguel goes
on a rampage, sending Spider-People into every
corner of the multiverse to search for him.
His fervor is fueled by his own past mistakes,
but it’s hard not to see him as the villain.
As he himself says, being Spider-Man is about
sacrifice.
It requires a level of tragedy.
We see glimpses of Miguel’s own tragic backstory
and how he brought a whole dimension to its
knees by trying to have a happy life there
in hiding.
At least, we see his version of the story.
But is it possible that he’s wrong?
Miguel appears to be so lost in his own pain
and torment that he’s incapable of thinking clearly.
So far, the "Spider-Verse" films have been
about realizing that we can make our own paths.
Perhaps Miguel can still learn that lesson
somewhere down the line.
After leading the Spider-Society on a wild
goose chase away from their headquarters,
Miles sneaks back into the base and uses the
transdimensional portal tech to go home.
He arrives in New York on a dreary, rainy
night, and as he runs home, he’s haunted
by his doubts and fears.
He hears Miguel’s words in his head telling
him that he’s a mistake, but he just keeps
running until he gets home.
There he finds his mother, Rio, to whom he
finally confesses his identity as Spider-Man.
All is not as it seems, though, as Rio has
no idea who Spider-Man is, and Miles quickly
discovers that Miguel’s machine sent him
back to his spider’s universe, not to his.
Now trapped in a dystopian world where his
father died instead of his uncle, Miles desperately
tries to conceive of a plan to get home.
The moment he realizes he’s in the wrong
universe is a powerful and unsettling moment.
There’s an uncanniness to his conversation
with his mother that drives home just how
out of place he actually is, even before the
truth is fully revealed.
Just before, Miles delivers a powerful monologue
about how he’s finally embraced what he’s
capable of.
He conquers the doubts and fears that were
so vivid earlier, but now he faces his greatest
foe of all: himself.
It doesn’t take long for Uncle Aaron to
discover that something’s off about Miles
on Earth 42.
In short order, he knocks his "nephew" out
and takes him to a secret hideout, where he
ties him to a punching bag.
Miles assumes that in this universe, his uncle
is still the Prowler, but he’s wrong.
The Prowler is Earth 42's version of Miles.
Having Miles literally confront himself is
a little on the nose, and yet, it works.
The face-off drives home how just a handful
of coincidences can completely change the
path a person goes down.
It also shows that there’s more than one
way to conquer your fears.
With "Across the Spider-Verse" ending right
after this confrontation, it appears that
Miles 42 will play a major role in the next
movie.
Giving the main character a shadow version
of sorts to play off of could be a great move
to allow for a deeper exploration of Miles’
character as a whole.
Gwen tries to follow Miles back to his home
dimension to help him, but when she gets to
his house, she realizes he was sent to the
wrong universe.
Remorseful for betraying him and determined
to get him back, she breaks from Miguel’s
core Spider-Gang and creates a new crew.
"I can't lose one more friend."
The roster includes herself, Peter B. Parker,
Pavitr Prabhakar, and a number of other kindly
Spider-Folks.
Most of the squad from the first film returns
to help her, which means Spider-Ham and Spider-Man
Noir will probably have more to do in "Beyond
the Spider-Verse."
Jessica Drew and Spider-Byte also end up helping
the new crew.
Spider-Byte has the option to shut down Miguel’s
portal before Miles can escape, but she chooses
to let him go.
Later, Jess locates Gwen at Miles’ parents'
apartment, but she opts not to stop her or
even alert Miguel.
Clearly, both characters were touched by Miles
and Gwen’s speeches about how they’re
supposed to be the good guys.
They know that Spider-Man 2099 has gone too
far, but they’re not sure how to step away
from him without everything falling to pieces.
Though he’s ostensibly the primary villain
of the whole movie, The Spot’s role in "Across
the Spider-Verse" is more unique than that.
He spends half the film as a downright doofus,
the "villain of the week" archetype that Miles
makes fun of him for being.
But once he discovers the true potential of
his powers, he grows far stronger than anyone
could have predicted.
But we never actually see The Spot fully manifest
his new powers.
"Across the Spider-Verse" ends on what feels
like a second-act finale, with everything
going bad all at once and most of our characters
in peril.
The Spot gets a cool, spooky new look and
clearly intends to wreak havoc across the
multiverse, but his villainous plans take
a backseat to Miles’ dimensional displacement
and the reveal of the new Prowler.
It will be interesting to see how big of a
role Spot plays in "Beyond the Spider-Verse."
Though he’s incredibly powerful now, he
doesn’t fully escape the label of a joke character.
Now that Miles is stuck on Earth 42, it might
make sense to focus more on the antagonists there.
At the very least, though, a climactic battle
between the Spider-Society and The Spot seems
inevitable, especially since we don’t get
one at the end of "Across."
When "Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse" was
released in 2018, it broke the mold of both
superhero movies and animated features.
With its blended visual style, bright colors,
sharp contrasts, and comic book aesthetic,
it delivered something completely new for
American animation.
And with "Across the Spider-Verse," Sony has
broken the mold once again.
The boldest visual choices from the first
film are magnified tenfold in the sequel.
Backdrops fizzle and buzz as if they’re
covered in a technicolor haze.
Harsh color blasts every scene, echoing the
emotions of the characters and changing with
every cut.
And of course, more Spider-Man variants mean
more animation styles, all of which meld together
in a mesmerizing tornado of motion and flair.
The ending of "Across the Spider-Verse" brings
all of this visual diversity to bear, splitting
focus between a half dozen different dimensions
and embodying all of Miles and Gwen’s despair
in vivid hues.
There may not be a big climactic battle before
the credits cut things off, but the emotion
truly peaks in the final minutes of the film.
And it’s all thanks to the animation.
In a way, this is the film’s greatest trick:
eschewing a traditional third act in favor
of a powerful emotional rush that only the
"Spider-Verse" style can deliver.
In addition to the overarching coming-of-age
narrative, one of the main themes in "Spider-Man:
Across the Spider-Verse" is the relationships
between parents and their children.
The story kicks off in Gwen’s dimension,
where she struggles to connect with her dad
thanks to their shared trauma and her secret
identity.
Miles has a similar dilemma, wanting to both
keep his parents close and "spread his wings,"
as he puts it.
Later on, we meet Mayday, Peter B. Parker
and Mary Jane’s daughter.
Peter tells Miles that it was only because
of him that he felt comfortable becoming a father.
Miguel explains that he once tried to join
a universe where he had a wife and child and
that his mere presence was enough to unravel
the fabric of existence.
That experience is what threw him into his
current state of brooding.
And of course, the thing that causes Miles
to clash with Miguel is the idea that he can’t
save the life of his own father.
The death of parental figures is supposedly
an unshakeable aspect of every Spider-Hero’s
story, but Miles refuses to accept that as
a fact.
Because "Across the Spider-Verse" ends on
such a big cliffhanger, this theme of parenthood
also doesn’t get fully resolved.
There’s a nice scene of reconciliation between
Gwen and her dad, but we don’t actually
know what will become of Miles’ father,
or if Miguel can be dissuaded from his strict ways.
If Peter B. and Mayday are any indication,
though, families are stronger when they fight together.
The core plot conceit of "Across the Spider-Verse"
involves the so-called "canon events" that
are part of every Spidey’s story.
Simply by invoking the term "canon," the movie
presses squarely up against the fourth wall.
There are a few other overt references to
meta storytelling in the movie, such as during
Gwen’s art gallery battle against Vulture.
Numerous previous "Spider-Man" movies are
invoked as well.
Donald Glover’s Prowler from "Homecoming"
pops up, a stray joke nods to the multiversal
chaos in "No Way Home," and there are clips
from both the Andrew Garfield and Tobey Maguire series.
All of this meta-commentary is part of the
film’s irreverent style.
It’s a signature of Christopher Miller and
Phil Lord’s brand, and it fits with the
natural humor of the "Spider-Man" comics.
However, there are deeper layers to all the
"canon" references.
The fact that Miguel, a character who’s
pretty clearly overzealous and in the wrong,
cares so much about preserving the canon could
be read as a jab at the modern franchise model.
Franchises like the MCU spend inordinate time
tying everything together, and "Spider-Verse"
seems to be at least a bit critical of that
idea.
The concept of "canon" also fits with Miles’
personal journey.
At one point he tells Miguel,
"Everyone keeps telling me how my story is
supposed to go.
Nah.
I’ma do my own thing."
His mother repeatedly encourages him to carve
out his own place in the world, regardless
of if it’s typical, or even if it’s canonical.
"It’s all possible."
That’s what Gwen says Miles taught her when
talking to his parents at the end of "Across
the Spider-Verse."
She spends the majority of the film doing
exactly what Miguel and Jess tell her to do.
She buys into the idea that there’s only
one right way to go about things.
And in fairness to her, it makes sense why
she thinks that.
Gwen has clearly been powerfully lonely since
Peter’s death, and she’s willing to follow
the Spider-Society’s lead as long as it
gives her a home.
But Miles wrecks that entire framework.
For much of the movie, he also wants to join
the crew, but he quickly learns to trust his
gut instead of just following the crowd.
In his heart, he knows that being a hero is
about trying to do the right thing, even when
it might be impossible.
Miguel may have experienced great calamity
in his time, but Miles refuses to believe
that that makes it inevitable for everyone.
This is where Miles’ status as the "original
anomaly" takes on more significance.
His mere existence proves that not everything
people think they know about the multiverse
is true.
And in an extratextual sense, he represents
the idea that deviations are always possible.
In fact, according to Miles, it’s all possible.
Perhaps the most striking thing about the
end of "Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse"
is how abrupt it is.
The closest thing we get to a climactic action
set piece is the chase scene through Spider-Man
2099’s reality.
Everything that follows is much more focused
on emotional storytelling than the action.
In the end, Miles is still tied to a punching
bag, Miguel is hunting him down, and Gwen
is in the middle of her search for him.
Even The Spot ends his arc midway through
before he can really reveal what he intends
to do.
If you didn’t already know that "Beyond
the Spider-Verse" was coming in 2024, the
sudden cut to credits might catch you completely
by surprise.
"Across the Spider-Verse" is not exactly a
short movie, but it moves quickly enough that
it would be easy to imagine another 30 minutes.
But then, that’s part of the point.
"Across the Spider-verse" deals with messy
topics, broken relationships, unsettled trauma,
and a love story that keeps hitting roadblocks.
"Look at you."
"Look at me."
It’s a movie about growth and independence,
but not necessarily one about resolution.
At the end of things, no one is really where
they’re supposed to be, but they all possess
the will and confidence to get back where
they want to be.
And that, perhaps more than anything else,
is what "Across the Spider-Verse" is really about.
As compelling as the messy ending to "Across
the Spider-Verse" is, it’s also exciting
to look ahead at what could be coming in the
third film.
"Spider-Man: Beyond the Spider-verse" is currently
slated for release on March 29, 2024, less
than a year out from the "Across" premiere.
And given the state of the multiverse at the
end of the most recent film, the third entry
could be the most exciting yet.
Pretty much every major storyline is hanging
after "Across."
Will the timing ever work out for Miles and
Gwen?
Will the new crew be able to stop The Spot?
Can Miles save his father from a canonical
death, or will Miguel be proven right in the end?
And perhaps most pressing of all, how will
Miles balance his newfound superhero confidence
with the rest of his regular life?
Suffice it to say, there’s a ton of material
for "Beyond the Spider-Verse" to explore.
It seems unlikely that Miguel will be a villain
forever, especially since several of his closest
allies have already started to turn against
him.
And since all the Spider-Man variants from
the first movie come back at the end to help
Gwen, it’s likely we’ll get more of them
next time as well.
Whatever happens, "Beyond the Spider-Verse"
should be a fun ride as long as it holds onto
the sharp style that’s made the series so
popular.